[Music]
in ready to rumble news you won the
wombo submitted by Bernardo from Houston
wow you're a weird guy the old blues
clues huh
just one note I need practice you're out
of breath the old blues clues host
challenged John Cena to a fight Steve or
Joe deep ok
what's blues clue you know Joe doesn't
count all right Joe doesn't care what's
Blue's Clues
hey Joe are you guys saying what are you
saying
he's the host of Blue's Clues you see
the guy with the original dude the og
double G oh thank you Steve can someone
tell me what blues clues is we're too
old for that [ __ ]
it's a children's show that ran in the
late 90s - like what like in a cartoon
show or what kind of show I have two
younger brothers say Barney my youngest
brother watch blues clematis or pajamas
like that it was like the first green
screen kids show yeah so there's just
one like living person but everything
else is animation it's like the
weatherman he's like hey I'm here with
blue I think he's right there like that
kind of Blues a cg that's like Bobby's
world where like there's Howie Mandel
with Bobby dude totally but that was
animated anime gotcha okay forget it
this all sprouted because of rounded I
don't know it's pretty nailed it okay
sure and now can you tell me who John
Cena's don't see I know Justin he's like
one of the most means people on the
planet I think you seem super nice
though he's really dope
John Cena it's good to see him ray he's
nice alright so Jason Lynch which is ad
weeks senior editor for bad week he
tweeted out a photo of John Cena on a
stage where it says Blue's Clues and
then it says it's me
and then he was just something like just
joking around the lines like he's gonna
be the new host of Hobbit dope because
they have announced that they will be
vamping Blue's Clues even next to that
giant font
he looks huge what is he like seven feet
dude look at that shirt manager it's
struggling around you just went crazy
like oh my gosh John Cena is gonna be
the new host of Blue's Clues
his voice is way too raspy and scary
yeah and then he also added fuel to that
what a clue by posting on Instagram a
photo of Steve and with no caption he
just posted this photo of Steve over the
same shirt with he really really wants
this job man 2 he's bald down here
that's the main reason why they switch
them off for Joe who we hate Joe what
does Joe look like he's has a lot of
hair mmm [ __ ] that hair you have an
orange shirt yeah who wears the orange
shirt they couldn't just put a [ __ ]
weight on the guy his name is Joe right
yeah oh yeah it is well he's a new host
for Blue's Clues nailed it
yeah I was this dude oh we hate this guy
why what's so different about him you
look you look at him looking and looking
it's hard to hate someone doing my back
itches didn't you just put your mouth on
the mouth goes on this side this side
goes for back skin yeah he would change
his shirt colors he wasn't the og why
don't you like him because he looks like
a like a lesbian lady no you know that
NEMA Drake where it's like Drake's
pointing it you're like we're like he's
pointing at Steve from Blue's Clues
yeah and it's like he's points at Joe
from Blue's Clues and he's like mom and
he points to Steve from Bustos and he's
like he's like yeah it's like that it's
just like that it's that simple
you see Steve and you're like I like it
you see Joe and you're like man listen
Joe looks like somebody who doesn't want
to be gender specific yeah what's the
name of that show won't where you can't
tell if the person was a guy or girl its
path yeah great that's old-school I love
that [ __ ] so then that's when TMZ was
interviewing Steve Byrnes and he said
this
see him now oh they kept his real name
Steve
I like the idea personally that um yeah
that's good
that the host of blue suppose could be
like a regular looking guy he you know I
mean like I didn't look like you know
Justin Bieber or anything like that I
was just kind of a normal weird dude you
know and I like the idea that the host
of that show really could be your friend
really could be someone who you might
meet and who isn't like a super buff
amazing professional wrestler
I think if John Cena is serious about
hosting Blue's Clues he and I should
wrestle for it yeah I'm calling you out
Cena right now did we like him see we
just might just gonna just is gonna die
yeah I don't like I don't like I don't
like Josephine Joseph it's a guy I don't
know about that we'll see I don't like
playing these feminine qualities yeah I
think the makeup artist went a little
bit too dark on the eyebrows I think
that's what happened oh and the blush I
just want to say I don't like putting
genders on people until I talk to them
and ask them what their gender is so
let's just say he's he's unclassified
yeah it looks like an alpha in a lesbian
relationship
well this fools real name is Donovan
pectin Donovan Donovan Patton Donovan's
a cool name
I like Donovan Donovan was the name of
my best friend in junior high that
disappeared disappeared do you sometimes
Facebook stock oh I should look him up
so when I do that when people pop into
my head oh so you just made that up and
like disappear and his parents are
crying because he can't find him no he
literally bounced so I mean him I went
to a junior high in like so so I went to
a junior high that's not part of the
track of your elementary school you
don't tell me not everyone in this
elementary goes through this junior high
but because I was such a bad kid I went
to a weird oh the one that's out of
Europe we called it Abraxas in our area
a prat that's where all the bad kids go
yeah so I went to I went to that
elementary school and then some when I
went to junior high I went back to the
one we're all supposed to go to I had no
friends and then so when I met this kid
and Donovan we were a hell of good
friends we kicked it off real good for
like the first two weeks and then he
just bounced and I was so sad and I
don't even know what happened to two
weeks and this has lasted this long in
your head what you guys do man I just
didn't have any friends I know if any
fun who's the only guy the impacted your
life yeah you guys just drink orange
soda outside a 7-eleven and [ __ ] just
enough yeah play basketball they have
two weeks affected you that much that's
crazy I'm saying I hope my friends do to
my heart David I can't remember who my
best friend was in middle school no idea
how could even remember it was two weeks
model of his two weeks but I remember
this short I remember I was like oh what
finally got a good friend and he just
bounced and I even asked a teacher I'm
like oh my head teacher can you call
miss Donna's parents know what's going
on is he coming back and they're like
all he's not coming back what the [ __ ]
he died and I found that he's like
getting home school or something it
wasn't long enough felt like he ran away
disappeared you speak English you always
claim this beautiful school for my life
when a kid goes to home scored is like
they die because I had an emotional
disappearance yeah I remember like in
second grade one of my classmates got
crushed by a gate we didn't see it
though but then there was a whole school
assembly to tell us about it it like
Falls no I he was playing like uh you
know those uh those automatic gates oh
yeah with the cars and stuff yeah he was
playing around there
and then he went to chase the ball and
then the car went through and he got
crushed by the game oh my god do you
live no he died oh my god but in they
had to have a school assembly to explain
to the kids like what's happening all
that stuff and then during the whole
time I was like everyone's sad I think I
should be sad too so let's just join the
sadness but I really feel sad you just
didn't register
you got any much I was just like
honestly I was like he's stupid everyone
knows not to chase the ball the mark of
a true sociopath is to mimic the
behavior of others to blend in
everyone was all sat in this assembly
and all he was playing his head dude
dude yeah dude and he's like I guess I
should feel sad I will act this way
yeah damn just we're talking about child
deaths in elementary school I remember
my brother because we took Tech Wando
together and my brother was actually
really good there's this other kid who
also technic window and he wanted to
like fight my brother in the further
school that's [ __ ] I remember my
brother [ __ ] his sidekick is full in the
face and I was like dude that do got his
ass [ __ ] look it was tight later on
and turned out a couple weeks later that
boy had a heart attack and died because
of that
no he had a overgrown heart as a purple
belt in Taekwondo I have to I have to
call out your friend or your brother my
brother so I'm a purple belt in
Taekwondo and you should only use it for
defense and never for attack oh there it
is I will say this as a professional
Taekwondo broke that puck in Taekwondo
honor I was 7 years old when I was
handing my parole oh damn from Amador Jo
you know that he confronted him and
that's the first time I just saw my
brother get into a fight and he actually
like psyching this kid in the face you
think your brother was [ __ ] Brad yeah
I thought no I thought was pretty damn
cool it's really cuz like you don't
really you don't really think that's
ever gonna work in real life even as a
kid you know what I mean like I was like
I'm not sure if I look at the kicks on
my in the face what would you have done
if he it was about to go down right here
like oh man his boy is gonna get his ass
beat cuz my brother is dope and then
your brother busts one of these I will
say this my brother did protect me once
in elementary school so there's this
like sixth grade dude that was like
basically was playing basketball and
then we were playing with my friends and
that's 6th grade do try to take my
basketball for me and my friends and my
friends being a little [ __ ] [ __ ]
that they were what we're just gonna
give the ball away and so they gave him
the ball
I was like no I [ __ ] rip the ball at
the deuce hands and that guy came up and
he [ __ ] sock me so my brother came up
and he pushed the do deals like y'all
leave my little brother alone and as my
brother was walking away with me he
turned on a [ __ ] sucker punched my
brother from the back and you might hear
the [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] is so after that
[ __ ] happen right we had like this
conference where you know you kind of
meet in both parents come I'm
overhearing with ketchup stains and the
next thing he comes in in a suit and tie
oh all property more glasses out of no
wallet gentle the gentleman to my left
yeah exactly
so [ __ ] mad but I will say this it
was lightweight embarrassing my brother
got sucker punch but it was a sucker
punch so I gave to him maybe your
brother's so ugly that he thought he's
punching a brother in the face
[Laughter]
come get a David let's go back to the
story it turns out that that photo of
John Cena was taken at Nickelodeon's up
front event and it was not a real a
casting call there they're actually
going to be looking for the new host I'm
pretty sure they're not gonna choose a
[ __ ] four year old roided man to be
the Blue's Clues guy oh my god pretty
intimidating yeah for kid everyone
believed it though everyone I would be a
terrible idea
we should start a campaign to get David
McDavid southern new hosted Blue's Clues
I'll be damned kids go [ __ ] find [ __ ]
I'd be great he's like that's the letter
hey you don't want it to be a letter eh
I'll beat the [ __ ] out of you try a
stance or [ __ ] you little [ __ ] back a
piss-poor fight you'll be getting into
fights every day I don't even smoke I'm
a light a cigarette
the [ __ ] you say to me blue what the
[ __ ] did you say to me blue yeah that's
what I thought you better shut the [ __ ]
up I'm not a [ __ ] to have like a Spike
Lee [ __ ] like Colorado no no no
that'd be tight probably that is how
that's a good blue I used to do it all
the time with my little brothers what a
loser when did you stop watching Blue's
Clues when I was 11
oh that's different that's 22
[Music]
[Music]